how do I know that the person I'm going
to hire you don't
I get Gary
I've got really good hiring advice learn
to fire fast you guys have your ego tied
up in your hiring you think you're so
good at hiring and then you hire
somebody and they're but you may
pretend they're not because firing them
admits that you were wrong so it's your
own ego that's holding you back my ego
is only balanced by my humility I hired
somebody for hundreds of thousands of
dollars six months ago interviewed him
three times I fired him one day into
working at vaynermedia I'm like
check your ego in the door you're not
that great at hiring but good
news nobody is